تاريخي يخطف انظار العلم
وروائع الموجي تضيء سماء الفن العربي
وبملايين المشاهدات سعد المجرد يعود
للغناء اهلا بكم الى تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بعد ثمانيه اشهر على وفاه الملكه
اليزابيث
لاطول حكم لملك في تاريخ بريطانيا
رسميا للبلاد في احتفال تاريخي حضره عشرات
الالاف ما بين ضيوف ورؤساء الدول وكبار
الشخصيات والبريطانيين وبالاقرار الى
المسح بالزيت المقدس ومنحه التاج
والصولجان والكره الذهبيه اعلنت تشارلز
ملكا رسميا ومن اللافت في حفل التتويج هو
عدد من الاختلافات والاضافات التي اضافها
الملك تشارلز الثالث على الحفل من ناحيه
الحضور الذين تم دعوتهم لا يتجاوز عددهم
الفي شخص بينما تجاوز عددهم في تتويج
الملكه اليزابيث 8000 ضيف ايضا من
الاختلافات التي اضافها الملك تشارلز الى
مراسم التتويج هو تتويج زوجته كامله الى
جانبه في كاتدرائيات وسميستر ومنحها لقب
الملكات بالاضافه الى الذي اضاف له الملك
تشارلز مقدمه بانه سيسعى الى تعزيز بيئه
يمكن للناس من جميع الاديان والمعتقدات
العيش فيها بحريه تم ايضا تقليل عدد ساعات
مراسم التتويج من ثلاث ساعات الى ساعتين
فقط كما تم اختصار الطريق التي اطل بها
الملك تشارلز وزوجته على جموع من ويسمن
الى قصر لمده اربعين دقيقه اما في تتويج
الملكه اليزابيث فتم اتخاذ طريق اخر واطلت
الملكه على الجموع لمده خمس ساعات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والذي وثقت له الكاميرات صورا ولقطات
عفويه سرقت الاطوار
عبر
الصحفيه اهلا بك في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه
حفل تاريخي ملكي والاضخم منذ سبعه عقود لو
نبدا بالحديث بدايه عما ميز هذا الحفل
الملكي لاختلافات واللمسات التي اضافها
الملك تشارلز الى مراسم الحفل التاريخي من
بينها مقدمه القسام جلوس زوجته كاميلا
بجانبه اضافه الى اختصار وقت المراسم
نعم كان بالفعل يوما تاريخيا كما ذكرتي
وليس فقط يعني على الصعيد الداخلي في
بريطانيا وانما على الصعيد العالمي ايضا
وهذا يعني ممكن تفسيره من خلال الحضور
العالمي من من
شخصيات رفيعه ومن ملوك ولكن كانت هناك
مفارقات كثيره ما بين حفل التسويج الذي
جرى امس في رؤيه واسمنسر وحفل تتويج والده
الملك تشارلز الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه في
عام
فالمفارقات كانت كثيره ولكن على راسها هو
تقليص كل شيء وخاصه التقليص المادي وخاصه
بان البلاد البريطانيا كباقي الدول العالم
تعصف بها مشاكل يعني اقتصاديه وماليه
كبيره وهناك بعض الانتقادات التي كانت
تتطال الملكه تشارل العائله الملكه في
الفتره الاخيره بسبب يعني
دفع المبالغ الطائله بحيث حتى هذا التتويج
الذي كان يعني اصغر بكثير من التتويج
الملكه منذ 70 عاما ولكن كانت تكلفته 100
مليون جنيه استرليني ولكن المفارقات
الاخرى كما ذكرتي بان كان هناك يعني حوار
للاديان واضح جدا وهذا ما اراده ملكه
تشارلز خاصه وانهم قريب جدا من الديانات
الاخرى وخاصه الاسلاميه ويتكلم العربيه
وكانت هناك ترانيم ارثوذكسيه تكريما او
تخليدا لذكرى والده الامير فيلب الذي كان
ارثوذكسيا وكانت والدته تحولت الى راهبه
ودفنت في القدس فكانت هناك بعض الحيات
التي اختارها الملك تشارز بنفسه لتكون
مميزه بالاضافه الى الكثير من الحيثيات
العصريه التي كانت واضحه جدا على الحفل
لاول مره حضور ممثلين بكولوس ديانات في
كسر اعتبر للتقاليد الملكيه طيب جوسلين
الامير الغائب الحاضر يثير الجده المره
الجديده الامير هاري حضر مراسم الحفل
والتتويج في الصف الثالث بعيدا عن افراد
العائله الملكيه وبعدها غاب عن موكب الملك
وعن شرفه القصر كيف تقيمين حضور هاري
اعتقد برايي المتواضع بان ما حدث وما
شاهدناه امس بالنسبه للامير هاري كان
متوقع
فدعيه هو وزوجته لحضور الحفل ولكن اعتذرت
هي عن الحضور بسبب عيد ميلاد ابنها ولكن
لم يعني يقال ابدا بانه سيحضر على الشرفه
لسبب واضح وصريح جدا ليس له علاقه
بالعلاقه
المترديه بينه وبين والده والملكه كاملا
واخيه الامير ويليام ولكن اختصر الوضع كله
الملك تشارز من خلال القول بان من سيقف
على الشرفه هو من الاعضاء اعضاء العائله
المالكه الفعالين الذين يملكون وظيفه وهو
تخلى عن وظيفته الملكيه هو والامير
انجرو لم يتخلى لديه يعني مشاكل اخرى فكان
الامر متوقع ولكن هناك من يقول في الصحافه
بعض الصحف البريطانيه بان بعض المحطات
التلفزه التي نقلت بقاء الحفل لم يعني
تتطرق كثيرا لوضع الكاميرا لرصد تحركات او
وضعيه الامير هاري يعني تم تهميشه اذا صح
القول وبالفعل هو
وترك الحرف شكرا شكرا لكم وقيل انه سافر
الى نيويورك عبر لندن الصحفيه جوسلين
ايليا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد على مسرح ابو بكر سالم
في بوليفارد رياض سيتي اعاده احدى ليالي
السعوديه الفنيه التاريخ العريق والفن
الاصيل الى قلوب عقول الجماهير العربيه
امسيه فنيه رائعه نظمتها الهيئه العامه
للترفيه لاشراف رئيس مجلس ادارتها
المستشار تركيا الشيخ وبالتعاون مع هيئه
الموسيقى و برنامج جوده الحياه وذلك
للاحتفاء بالنغم والطرب واصاله الفن
العربي عبر احياء روائع مهندس وسيد
الالحان الخالد الموسيقار الراحل محمد
الموجي محمد الموجي الموسيقار المصري الذي
رافق الفن على مدار 50 عاما من حياته وترك
فيه بصمات خالده لا تنسى وسجلا فنيا لا
يمكن احصائه الموجي الذي عناق العود من
الثامنه من عمره واسست تجربه موسيقيه
خالده لروائع فنيه وسمعناها وعرفناها
وحفظناها بدءا من عام 1951 في صافيني مره
مرورا باكثر من
1800 اغنيه من الالحان الاصيله وانتهاء
بالروائع الثلاث يا ملك قلبي رساله من تحت
الماء وقرات الفنجان وعلى الرغم من رحيله
في
1995 عن الحياه الا انه خلف ارثا ضخما من
الاغاني والالحان التي اشتهر بها عمالقه
الفن العربي امثال عبد الحليم حافظ وام
كلثوم وصباح وطلال مداح وغيرهم
من شويه
واسالها انت وحل فيها على طول هتقول لك
[موسيقى]
هل انت وحل فات على طول هتقول لك هي
انت وبس اللي حبيبي
[موسيقى]
اوعوا
وكلام معسول واموت واسترجعه
[موسيقى]
يوما مكسورا
نور
اناديله
وبحبك قد عيني
حتى اكتر من
شويه قرب من مايو كانت رياضه على موعد مع
ليلى فنيه استثنائيه اصبحت ملاذا لكل حال
ومتذوق للفن العربي الاصيل واضطر منظمها
والقائمون عليها الى توسعه الحفل عده مرات
بسبب الاقبال الكبير على الحفل كان رئيس
مجلس اداره هيئه الترفيه تركيا للشيخ اعلن
عن توسعه الحفل للمره الثالثه واعتذر عن
عدم قدره توسعه اكثر من ذلك فهي ليست ليله
فنيه عاديه وانما ليله تكريميه للموسيقار
محمد الموجي والتي تمت بحضور كوكبه من
الفنانين العرب واكثر من 130 عازفا شاركوا
في احياء وتجديد الحان الراحل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اشتقت
[موسيقى]
لا اشتاق
بحبكم قوي باي باي
ومن الفتاه الجميله والتي تعبر عن تاثر
الجماهير في الحفل وعن الاثر الكبير الذي
تركته والحان الموسيقار الراحل في نفوسهم
هي مسابقه اعلن عنها رئيس مجلس اداره هيئه
الترفيه تركيا الشيخ تتضمن تصوير كل محب
للطرب الاصيل والالحان محمد الموجي
لفيديوهات قصيره لا تتجاوز الدقيقه يظهر
فيها تاثرهم وتفاعلهم مع الحفر
[موسيقى]
علمني كيف
[تصفيق]
المجنون يسافر في كل الدنيا قد كلم امراه
الى ولدي
هي الدنيا
[موسيقى]
قالت يا ولدي
فالحب عليك هو
المكتوب يا
ولد ولم يخلوا حفل تكريم الراحل من
اللحظات المؤثره التي تصدرتها مشاهد تاثر
ابن الموسيقار الراحل يحيا الموجي خلال
عزف مقطوعه ضمن احد اشهر الحان والديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ونحن في تفاعلكم توصلنا مع ابن الموسيقى
محمد الموجي الذي خص البرنامج بهذه
الكلمات متابعه
في البدايه احب اشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واشكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين
سلمان بن عبد العزيز واحب اشكر ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان على
الاستقبال الرائع لاسره الموجي
والحفاوه البالغه ومش قادر اعبر عن فرحتي
بتكريم محمد الموجي
بالحدث المذهل ده اللي لم يحدث من قبل
واحب اشكر طبعا معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ على استقباله لنا
واستقبلنا في بيته ومرحب بينا
ثقته فيا كمان في انه اداني كمان بتاعته
علشان اعزف بها في الحفله
اعدت بها الصوره بتاعت الماء العب بيها
الصوره بتاع
الساحه الماء والكمان قديما اغلى الكمنجات
اللي في العالم
قديمه جدا
يعني عمرها حوالي 300 سنه فالحقيقه كنت
خايف عليها جدا
وبلعب عليها وانا حريص جدا
طبعا في البدايه
احنا من شهرين بنجهز للاغاني اتصل بيا يا
معلم المستشار تركي وقال لي
احنا عايزين نعمل احتفال عليك بالمسيقار
محمد الموجي وعايزين نعمل اغانيه بشكل
جديد
تكتب لها هرمونيه وتحط لها توزيع واسترالي
تتعمل بشكل حديث شويه عشان برضو الشباب
اللي طالعين اليومين دول اييي يقدروا
يستوعبوا ويسمعوا الحان موسيقات محمد
الموجي وشكلها الجديد
وبالهارمونيات وبالاركسترا
فطبعا يعني بدلنا موجود جامد جدا
وعملنا حوالي خمس بروفات طبعا مايسترو
والمايسترو فايد ومع المطربين طبعا قمت
بالاشراف على العمل نفسه
وكنت بسمع المطرب كل واحد لوحده
ومحفظهم وبقول لهم على الكلمات لان انا
طبعا حافظ موسيقى محمد الموجي كلها
بالكلمات كمان فيعني حفظتهم كلهم تقريبا
الاغاني
[موسيقى]
وقمت بالاسراف على العزف على عزف الفرقه
الموسيقيه طبعا كانوا رائعين
وكمان يعني انا مش عارف اعبر عن فرحتي
فعلا
محمد الموجي وبشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وشكرا جزيلا
من الصعوبات التي تواجه الفنان المغربي
سعد المجرد الا انه عاد الى الساحه الفنيه
من جديد وبقوه نستطيع تسميات عوده بانها
عوده مليونيه خاصه انه تصدر ترند والمنصات
ومحركات البحث سعد المجرد الذي امضى ايامه
منذ اواخر فبراير في السجن في باريس بعد
انقضت محكمه فرنسيه عليه بالسجن ست سنوات
بتهمه اغتصاب فتاه فرنسيه في اكتوبر 2016
استانف حكم المحكمه وتم اطلاقه سراحه بشكل
مشروط منذ اسبوعين وتم الاعلان عن بقائه
تحت اشراف قضائي بانتظار محاكمته الجديده
وبشرط بقاء مكان سكني في باريس كان سعد
نشر على حسابه على انستجرام بوست شكر فيه
كل من وقف الى جانبه في هذه المحنه
واوضحها اليه اطلاق سراحه وقال انه لا
نهايات حزينه لمن يثق بالله واعلن عن
اغنيه جديده في الرابع من مايو الاغنيه
اسمها شخبارك وتم اطلاقها من يومين وتصدرت
المركز الثاني في الترند وحصلت على اكثر
من خمس ملايين مشاهده بعد يومين فقط من
طرقها
ايش اخبارك لا باس عليك ويا الحبيبه واش
مازال ولا محال
فين هاد الغيبه وشكون اللي شافك من هذا
العارفاني ولا محمد واش اخباري قوليلي
[موسيقى]
الحبيبه واش مازال
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى خدام حلقه اليوم من
تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]